we are mourning the loss of a legendary
performer today Dame Angela Lansbury was
just 17 when she started in Hollywood
with an Oscar name an oscar-nominated
part in the film Gaslight she went on
look at Angela there she went on to
iconic roles on screen in The Manchurian
Candidate and of course Beauty and the
Beast just to name a few couple also on
stage in shows like Sweeney Todd and
Mame Lansbury died just five days shy of
her 97th birthday Jamie wax takes a look
back at her extraordinary eight decade
career including the role she says was
most like herself
Angela Lansbury was perhaps best known
as the star of TV's Murder She Wrote
loved by millions as Jessica Fletcher
the mystery writer and amateur detective
who captured killers and captivated
viewers for 12 years does that suggest
anything to you Lansbury was born in
London in 1925 to escape the Blitz in
1940 her family moved to the U.S and
settled in New York it was just
wonderful I mean it was just everything
I had dreamed that it would be she made
13 films during her first decade in the
states
not this song later earning two Academy
Award nominations including a memorable
turn as the title character's mother in
The Manchurian Candidate you shoot the
presidential nominees through the head
as well as 15 Golden Globe nominations
and six wins I was lucky I was offered a
lot of things very fast but Lansbury
felt Typecast often playing someone
twice her age on camera so she went back
to her first love the stage where she
became an icon earning five Tony Awards
[Music]
off stage she juggled being a wife and
mother after more than 20 years on
Broadway Lansbury was ready for a change
and became a TV Legend as Jessica
Fletcher showing fellow seniors there
was life still to live which included
taking on multiple jobs including a role
in Disney's Beauty and the Beast as Mrs
Potts
slowly now don't spill and even sang the
title song Taylor's oldest time at the
age of 84 Lansbury returned to Broadway
for her final musical A Little Night
Music composed by long time friend
Stephen Sondheim proven yet again it's
never too late
for CBS mornings Jamie wax New York
she proved that over and over and over
again that it was never too late I think
what a beautiful life and what if there
is such a thing as a beautiful way to
die 96 to die peacefully after doing all
that she's accomplished I think that's
pretty nice and Murder She Wrote was a
huge it's been almost for us here here
at CBS spent almost all 12 of its
Seasons as a as a top-rated show in the
multi-generational show the fact that
you and I are familiar with it yeah says
a lot about 90s we were kids we did not
control the quicker it's on it was on